I'm really excited for this day so I'm
horrified
[Music]
every time was made during Prohibition I
know you make it in toilets that's about
it we might wake up in the woods
tomorrow
that's not moonshine that's just
cherries it is this the moonshine I
thought it came in a liquid form it's
moonshine soaked cherry that sounds like
some college level one two three oh my
god these don't taste like cherries why
don't you give me deer not you you gotta
work there very much I mean it just
makes me imagine what other things I can
silk and moonshine no for a second
you're like oh just a cherry like in my
Shirley Temple and then you're like no
this is deaf let's just be some apple
pie shot oh it smells amazing no it
doesn't it's a trick it's a trick it
smells like a candle that you would get
it that at Bath & Body Works okay that's
not bad it's like a big red stick of gum
as a shot it warms you in all the right
ways I would drink this on a cold
winter's evening I could I feel like I
could share one of these with my
grandmother I don't think you should do
that Linda's a feisty lady Oh strawberry
this smells awesome oh no it doesn't
this does smell like the middle
schoolers perfume though right it does
yeah
taking a jello shot the kick came it's
strawberry shortcake was a drunk this is
what she would drink people have been
like Alison you just have to find your
drink and I was like my drink doesn't
exist until now what is I don't like to
look at this one because it's clear this
one just looks like water Wow I can't
it's pretty corny pretty distinct
corniness coming through on this one if
we pour this on a table will there be a
hole in the table yeah it goes to the
back ear throat I'm gonna throw up
Oh
ah I definitely taste the corniness yeah
there's no skin corn in here it's just
terrible dick corn
that's a mean drink this looks like
poison so this is the real real real
moonshine this is literally like someone
made this and sold it on Etsy like this
is not a legit alcohol I don't like how
I can see through it
oh you're so yeah oh why whoa that's so
strong I just drink gasoline this this
stance for hit you [ __ ] weed that's 90%
alcohol are you serious is this legal
what's the rest of it what's the rest of
the 10% like a whisper that says get
drunk I need to call my parents
we've learned that moonshine comes in
all shapes and sizes sometimes it's
beautiful strawberry flavored it's like
feminism
I think the stereotype is that moonshine
is just strong liquor when really
there's a very distinct corn flavor if I
drink moonshine I would have another
persona called like midnight Amy she
died work I already do have an alternate
persona called midnight Amiens
why just say yes I think I thought it
smelled because I and tasty out I can't
see
[Laughter]
[Music]